chin Chi I browse nose jaw I laugh Jenni
JWoww Farley getting candid with me
about plastic surgery the headlines that
color unrecognizable and her body
transformation after baby number two you
posted on your Instagram this picture of
you at the VMAs I actually pulled the
quote you said I've never felt more
beautiful now the top to me about that
and the body transformation this time
around with Milani I actually never lost
all the baby weight so going into um my
pregnancy with Grayson I was already
starting out ten pounds heavier this way
to freak out moment am I gonna lose it
am I gonna feel insecure but can I
handle that criticism again cuz there's
a lot of criticism I really wanted this
and I actually set the goals of VMAs I
said I'm gonna do it I don't lose the
weight I actually think you told ET a
couple months ago after every post you
feel criticized do you still feel that
way
oh yeah but there's this new thing on
Instagram where you can take the
comments off cuz yeah I feel credit all
the time um where I don't post pictures
this is how bad I can get like at the
VMAs you look you're a drug addict and
your kids should be taken away from you
and I was like oh yeah and I was like ok
here we go the fact that like a picture
and how I looked how I felt under that
description that you read like someone
will write that to try and like take
someone down the go ninety awestruck
show it's kind of like my way to vent to
show we are great moms how do you handle
the media running headlines like JWoww
looks so different we can't even
recognize oh yeah how does that how do
you deal with that I got go top to
bottom chin cheeks eyebrows nose jaw
reconstruct all that good stuff
um I laugh I laugh cuz I haven't but
like I said I learned from makeup um my
weight fluctuates my tan fluctuates and
um I love that the way that I look so
different I take it as a compliment
because I don't want to look like the
girl that was 25 walking into the Jersey
Shore house setting
or with no knowledge on makeup you've
had to go and post you know makeup lists
selfies a lot and I've had to kind of
call out some outlets what is your
stance on plastic surgery I have no
objection I I'm always the one that says
do it for the right reason you do it for
cuz it's like truly what you want to
make yourself happy I'm 31 years old I'm
not getting any younger like I'm going
to do the non invasive surgeries and
things like that to stay youthful to
feel useful so I don't when I'm like 50
60 70 have to do the more dramatic ones
because I love the way I look I am
totally honest and open with it I do not
want a saggy face in 30 years whatever
your choice is I just say go for